فرانكي ، أوزة الحيوانات الأليفة تحب أن
تقضم طلاء أظافر مالكها ، وهذا في
الواقع أنا ، نعم ، شكرًا لك ، لكن
صريحك كادت أن تقضم
لنسر أصلع
، جاء النسر ينقض من السماء
ويمسك الإوزة حتى
ركضت أوزة أم بشرية حقيقية لإنقاذها
هل يمكنك وصف ما كنت ترتديه
كنت أرتدي الملاكمين من ماركة كوستكو الخاصة بزوجي ،
كيت أوكلي من جزيرة فانكوفر في
كولومبيا البريطانية ، كانت كندا
ترضع طفلتها عندما
سمعت أوزة حيوانها الأليف ، نعم ، فتاة جيدة
عند الباب تصدر مكالمة استغاثة
تتحدث عن أم متعددة المهام  أثناء
استمرارها في الرضاعة الطبيعية ،
خرجت من الباب مما تسبب في إسقاط النسر
لصريح الذي عولج إلى المنزل ،
ولم يكن كل الأبطال يرتدون ملابس ، كما نشر أحد
المعجبين
، سروال القبطان الحقيقي يهز
الآخر
بين الملاكمين والطفل الذي يمسك به ،
أعني نعم هناك الكثير
إذا توقفت كيت عن ارتداء ملابسها
، لكانت أوزة فرانكي مطبوخة على
شكل جينيموز سي إن إن
جديد
فينيويورك